Hey, Will. Hey. Oh, you ready to laugh today? Yeah, you really laugh today? Yeah, ready? One, two, three. Okay, here you go. Uh.
嘿，威尔。嘿。噢，你今天准备好大笑了吗？是啊，你今天真的要大笑吗？是啊，准备好了吗？一，二，三。好了，给你。呃。
Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh.
呃。呃。呃。呃。呃。呃。呃。呃。
Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Uh. Hey, do you guys eat seafood last night? Scotty and I went to a seafood place. Oh.
呃。呃。呃。呃。呃。嘿，你们昨晚吃海鲜了吗？斯科蒂和我去了一家海鲜店。噢。
We went to, yeah, it was right up the street. Oh, you're asking if we did too by chance? Yeah. I had a bite of fish last night. I actually went out to dinner for the first time in a very long time last night. Is that a restaurant? Yeah.
我们去了，是的，就在那条街上。噢，你是想问我们碰巧也去了吗？是啊。我昨晚吃了一口鱼。其实我昨晚是好长一段时间以来第一次出去吃饭。那是家餐馆吗？是啊。
The four of us went out to have a little family dinner and it was very, very pleasant. That's nice. Well, now, see, I went to a, the place, I went to, you have to do a show, a vaccine card, you have to do a vaccine card, you have to show ID. You don't have to do that in LA when you go out, right?
我们四个人出去吃了一顿小小的家庭晚餐，非常非常愉快。那真不错。好吧，现在，你看，我去的那家店，你得表演一下，出示疫苗卡，你得有疫苗卡，你得展示身份证。你们在洛杉矶出去玩的时候不用那样做，对吧？
No, we didn't have to show any of that stuff. We should have. Well, we were eating outside. I wonder if that matters. Huh. No. But you had to show it there in Chicago? Yeah.
不，我们不需要展示任何那种东西。我们本该展示的。好吧，我们在外面吃。我不知道那有没有关系。哈。没有。但你在芝加哥必须出示它？是啊。
And then we had the, I got a little, because Will knows, I like lobster and seafood and crabs. Love it. And then, so it's all in my fingers. And before what I do is I take the lemon and I squeeze the lemon on my hands and then rub my hands together so that it doesn't smell. Okay.
然后我们吃了，我弄了一点，因为威尔知道，我喜欢龙虾、海鲜和螃蟹。超爱。然后，所以它全在我手指上了。我做之前是拿柠檬挤在手上，然后把手搓在一起，这样就不会有味道了。好的。
And then what? And then you dry them off? But isn't that, you make it sound like that's some special strategy you thought up. Isn't, don't they bring the lemon to the table for that purpose with the little cloth? No, you put the lemon on the food. I don't know that you're supposed to put it on your hands,
然后呢？然后你把它们擦干？但这难道不是，你把它说得好像是你自己想出来的什么特殊策略一样。难道他们不是为了这个目的带着小布巾把柠檬端上桌的吗？不，你把柠檬放在食物上。我不知道你是不是应该把它放在手上，
but I do. Well, listen, we can just, we can ask our mystery guests who seems to be a top chef contestant based on what we're able to see here and a male top chef contestant based on the David that was burped out before we got going here. As a top chef contestant.
但我会。好吧，听着，我们可以，我们可以问问我们的神秘嘉宾，根据我们在这里能看到的，他似乎是一位顶级大厨的参赛者，而且是一位男性顶级大厨参赛者，基于我们在开始之前听到的那个大卫的打嗝声。作为一名顶级大厨参赛者。
Listener, usually the mystery guest is a full mystery. So, but I don't know the last name yet. You don't know last name. So let's get right into it. Okay. You'll guess it right away. My mouth is watering.
听众朋友，通常神秘嘉宾是完全保密的。所以，但我还不知道姓氏。你不知道姓氏。那我们直接进入正题吧。好的。你马上就能猜到。我口水都要流出来了。
Well, throw some lemon in there. This guy is one of the funniest in the biz period. Makes me laugh a lot. I remember seeing him in SNL when I was a kid and everyone would imitate his characters. He's been on not one hit sitcom, but two hits sitcoms. How many people can say that?
好吧，往里面加点柠檬。这家伙是这一行里最有趣的人之一，句号。让我笑了很多次。我记得小时候看《周六夜现场》时，每个人都在模仿他的角色。他不仅出演过一部热门情景喜剧，而是两部。有多少人能这么说？
I was a huge fan of his latest talk show. So many movies, so many animated films, so many TV shows, so many laughs. David Spade. Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait, how did you guys do that little switch? David, who was like, who was in the background going,
我是他最新脱口秀的超级粉丝。这么多电影，这么多动画片，这么多电视节目，这么多笑声。大卫·斯佩德。等等，什么？等等，什么？等等，你们是怎么做那个小切换的？大卫，是谁在背景里喊着，
David. Oh yeah, Heather, you got popped for yelling David. Heather. Wait, but why? Heather got popped again. Well, hang on. I feel dumber than I usually feel on this show. Which is remarkable.
大卫。噢，是的，希瑟，你因为喊大卫被抓包了。希瑟。等等，但为什么？希瑟又被抓包了。好吧，等等。我觉得自己比在这个节目里平时感觉的还要笨。这很了不起。
Would you guys do a little switcheroo there on your? No, I just did it before he got on. Yeah. Oh, they put top chef contestant. Okay, so. That's pretty good. Wow. First of all, David, welcome.
你们刚才是不是做了一点小把戏？不，我只是在他上来之前做的。是啊。噢，他们放了顶级大厨参赛者。好吧，所以。那还不错。哇。首先，大卫，欢迎。
I want to say welcome because nobody's said it yet. So welcome. David, welcome. Really happy you're here. David, welcome to the little yourselves. Secondly, I want to say, and I don't know how you feel about it, Sean saying I used to watch him on SNL when I was a kid. So that feels terrible to begin with.
我想说欢迎，因为还没人说过。所以欢迎。大卫，欢迎。真的很高兴你在这儿。大卫，欢迎来到你们自己。其次，我想说，我不知道你对此有何感想，肖恩说我小时候常看他在《周六夜现场》的表演。所以这听起来太糟糕了。
I was a kid. Listen, I was so locked into the lemon squeeze story. It's compelling. Because why did he bail on that one? Yeah, stay tuned. Sean's like, guys, before we start, I've got this story about a lobster and it's fucking crushing wherever I go.
我当时还是个孩子。听着，我当时完全沉浸在挤柠檬的故事里了。这很引人入胜。因为他为什么在那件事上放弃了？是啊，敬请期待。肖恩就像是，伙计们，在我们开始之前，我有个关于龙虾的故事，无论我走到哪儿，它都火得不行。
So let me just, just go with it. And then it feels like it's tapering down. I'm going to bring on Spadoodle. The real handy tip he's figured out with shellfish. I was thinking, David, the other day, Jason and I played this Pro-M golf tournament and I was at the tee and I was about to see you off. They had all these kids like volunteers and this guy goes,
所以让我，就顺着说吧。然后感觉它好像在逐渐减弱。我要请出斯佩杜德尔（Spadoodle）。他发现的关于贝类的真正好用的小窍门。大卫，我前几天在想，杰森和我参加了那个职业业余配对高尔夫锦标赛，我在发球台，正要送你离开。他们有所有这些像志愿者一样的孩子，然后这家伙说，
not kids, these guys and whatever, this guy goes, as I'm about to see you off, he goes, well, I love Blades of Glory. It was my favorite movie when I was a kid. And I just stopped and I went, I was an adult when I made that. Yeah. And how old are you?
不是孩子，是这些家伙，不管怎样，这家伙说，就在我要送你走的时候，他说，我喜欢《荣誉之刃》。那是我小时候最喜欢的电影。我停下来，然后说，我拍那部电影时已经是成年人了。是啊。你多大了？
You look good. Wait a minute. I'm almost 52. David, let me, just to clarify, what year did you start SNL? So I can say I was a kid. I don't even, you know, I don't know if we should talk numbers,
你看上去不错。等等。我快52岁了。大卫，让我，澄清一下，你哪一年开始做《周六夜现场》的？这样我就可以说我当时还是个孩子。我甚至，你知道，我不知道我们是否应该谈论数字，
but it scares off fans. Let me think. I think SNL was 91. Yeah. I was 20. But David, you have been. Cue plummeting ratings. But David, you've been very funny and actively funny.
但这会吓跑粉丝。让我想想。我想《周六夜现场》是91年。是啊。我当时20岁。但大卫，你一直。收视率暴跌。但大卫，你一直非常有趣，而且活跃地有趣。
I agree. IE employed for a very long time and that is quite the gold ribbon in this. That's hard. Yeah, that's a hard part. Yeah. It's good for you. Yeah.
我同意。也就是说，被雇佣了很长一段时间，这在这一行里可是金牌勋章。那很难。是啊，那是很难的部分。是啊。这对你很好。是啊。
For so many years. But wait, I want to go back to the seafood because I always see you at that seafood place that you and I go to unless the end again. That story is a two-parter. Yeah. No, it'll be more.
这么多年了。但等等，我想回到海鲜的话题，因为我总是在那家海鲜店看到你，我和你常去的那家，除非再次结束。那个故事分两部分。是啊。不，还会有更多。
Barely a one-parter. Wait, what seafood place? I always see you at the... Stop saying seafood. Okay. It's so generic. Yeah. Hey, have you guys ever eaten seafood?
勉强算一部分。等等，什么海鲜店？我总是在……别再说海鲜了。好的。太笼统了。是啊。嘿，你们吃过海鲜吗？
Did you guys eat seafood last night? It was like us? No. We all didn't sync up on that one. Yeah. Here's life. I'll go first with my seafood stuff. This is the best podcast ever.
你们昨晚吃海鲜了吗？像我们一样？不。我们没在那件事上同步。是啊。这就是生活。我先说我的海鲜事。这是有史以来最好的播客。
I know. I was like, jeez, that's squeezing the lemon. It was like a car chase for that story. What restaurant do you guys... I always see you at Koi. We always go to Koi. I do. You know, Sean, I've seen at Koi.
我知道。我当时想，天哪，那是在挤柠檬。那个故事就像一场汽车追逐戏。你们去哪家餐馆……我总是在Koi看到你。我们总是去Koi。我确实。你知道，肖恩，我在Koi见过。
And we've never bought each other dinner and do that old funny trick. No, but I'm open to it. Yeah. I'll do it. I'll start. Wait, Koi's a sushi restaurant. Stop calling you a seafood restaurant.
我们从来没请对方吃过饭，玩那个老掉牙的有趣把戏。不，但我对此持开放态度。是啊。我会做的。我先来。等等，Koi是家寿司店。别再叫它海鲜店了。
Well, fishes are the ocean. Everything's really a seafood restaurant. And so it's spelled K-O-I, not C-O-Y, right? It's not like some sneaky little date place. It's called Koi. I always go, you want to go eat some sushi? And Scott, he'll go, oh, Koi. Oh, Koi?
好吧，鱼来自海洋。所有东西其实都是海鲜店。而且它是拼写为K-O-I，不是C-O-Y，对吧？它不是什么鬼鬼祟祟的小约会场所。它叫Koi。我总是说，你想去吃点寿司吗？然后斯科蒂会说，噢，Koi。噢，Koi？
You guys are so cute. No, but all kidding aside, one time I got food poisoning there. No, but we can't say that. We got to cut that out. No, you didn't hear what he said. Say it again, David. Food poisoning. Oh, food poisoning.
你们这些家伙太可爱了。不，但说正经的，有一次我在那儿食物中毒了。不，我们不能说那个。我们得把它剪掉。不，你没听见他说什么。再说一遍，大卫。食物中毒。噢，食物中毒。
No, I actually love Koi. I used to go to Koi back in my wet days. When it was cool. Well, I mean, it's still, that's my question. It's still there. Is it still bumping, as the kids used to say? You know, it was always bumping. And then it had a certain heyday with, like, Craig's,
不，我其实很喜欢Koi。我以前在我的湿润日子里常去Koi。当它还很酷的时候。好吧，我的意思是，它仍然，那是我的问题。它还在那儿。它还像孩子们过去常说的那样火爆吗？你知道，它一直很火爆。然后它有一段鼎盛时期，就像Craig's，
you know, a lot of cameras out front. And now that it's not, it's just still a good restaurant. It's the best. But it's not all commotion. Is the stinking rose still across the street? That's down Los Angeles. That's further down towards Wilshire. Ed DeBevix.
你知道，前门有很多摄像机。现在虽然不是了，但它仍然是一家好餐馆。它是最好的。但没有那么多骚动。臭玫瑰（The Stinking Rose）还在街对面吗？那是洛杉矶的下游。那是往威尔希尔方向更远的地方。Ed DeBevix。
Is Ed DeBevix still up and running? He's in LA. Ed DeBevix was on Melrose 18 years ago. No, that's way down. You're right. What about Flippers? Do you guys ever skate at Flippers? Are you thinking of the Sonic in Austin?
Ed DeBevix还在营业吗？他在洛杉矶。Ed DeBevix 18年前在梅尔罗斯大街上。不，那太远了。你是对的。那Flippers呢？你们去过Flippers滑冰吗？你在想奥斯汀的Sonic吗？
I'm thinking of a place that used to be where the Beverly Center is now built. Oh. Oh, no, that was the Odyssey, the Odyssey nightclub. No, you know, I do a lot of La Cienega. There's a Nobu on there. There's a lot of nice restaurants right there. Do you ever do a Fogo de Chao?
我在想一个过去在现在比佛利中心所在地的地方。噢。噢，不，那是奥德赛，奥德赛夜总会。不，你知道，我常去拉谢内加（La Cienega）。那儿有家Nobu。那儿有很多不错的餐馆。你们去过Fogo de Chao吗？
I'm Sean. I would think that you would like Fogo de Chao. Hey, watch the language, please, Wil. No, but somebody, my friend of mine just texted me last night a new documentary once again on the food industry. And now she's a vegan because of it. Some new documentary that's out on Netflix.
我是肖恩。我觉得你会喜欢Fogo de Chao。嘿，注意言辞，威尔。不，但有人，我的一个朋友昨晚刚给我发短信，又是一部关于食品工业的新纪录片。现在她因为这个成了纯素食者。Netflix上刚出的一部新纪录片。
So she's like, I went shopping. I'm not buying meat anymore. I watched a documentary on Netflix about food and it got me to go vegan for six months to try to drop my cholesterol. And so I didn't, all I had were plants for six months. My cholesterol dropped a single point. Oh, wow.
所以她说，我去购物了。我再也不买肉了。我在Netflix上看了部关于食物的纪录片，它让我尝试了六个月的纯素食，为了降低胆固醇。所以我没吃别的，六个月里只吃了植物。我的胆固醇只降了一个点。噢，哇。
Really? Yeah. So you're back on meat. Well, yeah, either meat doesn't matter for cholesterol or I've got some chronic cholesterol problem that it can't be fixed. And there's limited time. You look pretty healthy though
真的吗？是啊。所以你又开始吃肉了。好吧，是啊，要么肉对胆固醇没影响，要么我有什么无法修复的慢性胆固醇问题。而且时间有限。你看起来挺健康的。
because you're always pretty skinny and ripped. All you guys are pretty skinny and ripped. No one's really lost there. Well, that's nice of you. You spend time with Bateman in a meal situation. It's like a, like a supermodel trying to make weight. Like he's counting, he's annoying the waitress with like, you know the LA thing of like, I'd like to order this,
因为你总是很瘦，肌肉线条分明。你们所有人都很瘦，肌肉线条分明。没人真的在那儿输了。好吧，你真好。你和贝特曼一起吃过饭。就像一个，像一个试图控制体重的超级名模。就像他在计算，他在烦扰服务员，你知道洛杉矶那种，我想点这个，
but here are my conditions to my order. Meg Ryan order. Oh, shit. But it's so funny. If you put a brownie in front of him, he'll inhale it. That's the truth. Yeah, exactly. I just don't order it, but I will eat it.
但这是我对订单的要求。梅格·瑞恩式的点餐。噢，该死。但这太搞笑了。如果你在他面前放个布朗尼，他会吸进去。这是真的。是啊，没错。我只是不点它，但我会吃。
The only thing I've heard that you guys are all three at Aniston's house in different rooms. That's not true, is it? Right now? We've been living at Jen's house for years. I always, well, I see Jason over there and not to mention Jennifer Aniston on this, but Jason, that's when I was thinking of eating.
我听到的唯一一件事是你们三个都在安妮斯顿家不同的房间里。那不是真的，对吧？现在？我们已经在詹妮弗家住了好几年了。我总是，好吧，我看到杰森在那儿，更不用提詹妮弗·安妮斯顿了，但杰森，那是我想到吃的时候。
I think I've only seen you eat there. And I eat a lot. I do eat a lot. You do. And Will, I think I've seen all of you guys probably over there. By the way, David, I keep, I think about this all the time. Fuck it made me laugh so hard. A few years ago, I don't know if you remember,
我想我只见过你在那儿吃。而且我吃得很多。我确实吃得很多。你确实。还有威尔，我想我可能见过你们所有人在那儿。顺便说一句，大卫，我一直，我一直在想这件事。该死，它让我笑得太厉害了。几年前，我不知道你记不记得，
we went to some event and we were both presenting something. I forget what it was and somebody, there was a guy out doing some bit and it was bombing. And I think it was kind of the point of the thing that was, it was to bomb. And it was just like completely bombing. And we were standing next to each other just off stage and you turned to me and you go,
我们去参加某个活动，我们俩都在颁奖。我忘了是什么了，有人，有个家伙在做某个段子，结果冷场了。我觉得那冷场本身就是那个东西的重点。它完全冷场了。我们站在舞台边上，你转过头对我说，
he makes you look like a good actor. No, why would I say that? You had me, I literally bent over laughing. It was so funny. It was such a great burn. Here's my problem. I do stuff like that. The people I don't know well enough.
他让你看起来像个好演员。不，我为什么要那么说？你让我，我简直笑弯了腰。太搞笑了。那真是个绝妙的讽刺。这是我的问题。我做那种事。对那些我不够了解的人。
I'd like you and I think you're funny. And I don't know you well enough to start throwing out shitty jokes to you, but I can't help it sometimes because I think you're funny. So I go, this is like a gamble. Well, I get it because I think that, you know, again, this comes up a lot that that's the, that's kind of a language of love of like burning somebody. Like if it was somebody and give a shit, you'd be like,
我喜欢你，我觉得你很有趣。我还不了解你到可以开始对你开烂玩笑的程度，但我有时忍不住，因为我觉得你很有趣。所以我说，这就像一场赌博。好吧，我明白了，因为我觉得，你知道，这又来了，这是一种爱的语言，就像讽刺某人。如果那是某个人，我不在乎，你会说，
why am I, I'm not going to waste that joke on this idiot. I wouldn't even talk to you or you wouldn't talk to me. But I do that. I talked to Jason. I want to see him out because Jason's always interesting to talk to and Sean and I went to that seafood place. Boy. Wait a second.
我为什么要，我不会把那个笑话浪费在这个白痴身上。我甚至不会跟你说话，或者你也不会跟我说话。但我确实那样做。我跟杰森说话。我想见他，因为杰森总是很有趣，肖恩和我去了那家海鲜店。天哪。等一下。
I saw him at the seafood place, Black Angus, because they have shrimp. I mean, you do sound like somebody on a cruise ship, Sean. Oh, there's wonderful seafood at this place. I mean, what is wrong with you? You jump 20 years. You can eat seafood. You order fish some places. You know how easy,
我在那家海鲜店看到他，Black Angus，因为他们有虾。我的意思是，你听起来确实像游轮上的人，肖恩。噢，这家店有很棒的海鲜。我的意思是，你到底怎么了？你跳跃了20年。你可以吃海鲜。你在某些地方点鱼。你知道多容易，
do you know how easy it would be to assassinate Sean? There are two places you have to hang outside of. Chin Chin on Sunset and Koi. Chin Chin. By the way, it's so true. Chin Chin. Every time you're there, you're sure it's 1999. You're just positive it must be.
你知道暗杀肖恩有多容易吗？有两个地方你必须在外面蹲守。日落大道的Chin Chin和Koi。Chin Chin。顺便说一句，太真实了。Chin Chin。每次你在那儿，你都确定是1999年。你绝对肯定那一定是。
I met a date at Chin Chin in 2004. That's the only, that's the last time I've been there. It's right in Sunset Plaza. It's got a great location. Did you have a girlfriend now, David? Hey, Sean. Nice transition. Let's get into the personal stuff right now.
我2004年在Chin Chin约会过。那是唯一一次，那是我最后一次去那儿。它就在日落广场。位置很好。你现在有女朋友吗，大卫？嘿，肖恩。很好的过渡。让我们现在进入个人话题吧。
You know, I had a great girlfriend and then I'm... Don't bring us down. Yeah. Don't bring us down. Oh, we know she died. Did she have ship adjudged seafood reaction? She went in a different direction. She went in a different direction.
你知道，我曾有个很棒的女朋友，然后我……别让我们扫兴。是啊。别让我们扫兴。噢，我们知道她去世了。她有海鲜反应吗？她走向了不同的方向。她走向了不同的方向。
Hold on. What does that mean? That means she broke up with me. Oh, okay. Wait, I want to go back to the... Please, anything. We've only covered seafood, so is that where we're going? Did I ever tell you about the lobster?
等等。那是什么意思？那意味着她跟我分手了。噢，好的。等等，我想回到……拜托，什么都行。我们只谈了海鲜，所以这就是我们要去的地方吗？我跟你讲过龙虾的事吗？
I go, I think we didn't cover that right at the beginning. Here's the story we're going to cut out. Sean's going to hate me for saying this. About eight months ago, we flew... I got a ride with Sean to New York to Sean's very... Let's keep it in. And we're flying on a PJ. And I look over and the...
我说，我想我们刚开始没讲完那个。这是我们要剪掉的故事。肖恩会因为我说这个而恨我。大约八个月前，我们飞……我搭肖恩的车去纽约，去肖恩非常……让我们保留它。我们坐私人飞机。我往那边看，然后……
Sean and Scotty have chartered the flight. And the flight attendant comes and says, would you like your seafood? I'm not making this up because this is so relevant. And she comes back with... He's on a private jet. And she comes and she serves him lobster. Jesus Christ.
肖恩和斯科蒂包了飞机。空乘走过来问，你想吃海鲜吗？我没编造这个，因为这太相关了。她回来带着……他在私人飞机上。她走过来，给他端上了龙虾。天哪。
And so Sean starts squirting lemon on it, whatever. And he looks over and I'm taking a photo. And he goes, what are you doing? I go, this is just insurance. This is just insurance. You want a fucking private jet eating lobster? Which, by the way, never, ever happens. Like, that was one thing.
所以肖恩开始往上面挤柠檬，不管怎样。他往那边看，我正在拍照。他说，你在干什么？我说，这只是保险。这只是保险。你想要一架该死的私人飞机吃龙虾？顺便说一句，从来，从来没发生过。就像，那是一件事。
Oh, really? Yeah, one time, one time. They told the lobster, the good news is you're going to be on a private jet. And the lobster was like, oh. But wait, I want to go back to when you were talking about going up to Will and like, you know, you're a funny person. So you feel safe to take a risk with certain jokes. Like, where did that come from?
噢，真的吗？是啊，有一次，有一次。他们告诉龙虾，好消息是你将坐上私人飞机。龙虾当时就像，噢。但等等，我想回到你谈论走向威尔，就像，你知道，你是个有趣的人。所以你觉得冒险开某些玩笑很安全。那来自哪里？
Did you always do that as a kid? Because I think a lot of people making jokes is risk taking, especially like in personal settings. Where did that confidence come from to go, you know what, I'm going to go for it. I'm going to try it. God, you know what's funny? I don't even know if it's confidence.
你小时候一直那样吗？因为我觉得很多人开玩笑是在冒险，特别是在个人场合。那种自信来自哪里，让你说，你知道吗，我要去做了。我要试一试。天哪，你知道什么很有趣吗？我甚至不知道那是不是自信。
It's just at a certain point, I feel like, it sounds like I'm saying I'm well known, but it feels like people expect a certain thing from me, even if it's bus boys or people or a valet. When they see you for one second, they sort of want you to say something that they, if they're only going to see one, that would be sort of memorable.
只是在某个点上，我觉得，这听起来像是我在说我很出名，但感觉人们对我有一种期待，即使是服务生、人们或代客泊车。当他们看到你一秒钟时，他们有点希望你说点什么，如果他们只能看到一次，那会是某种值得纪念的东西。
I've seen other people do it. Because, you know, I try to be polite. I try to be nice to everyone, but if sometimes I will joke with people I don't know, even if they want me to stop by their table or something, just to be friendly and say something goofy about them, and then they laugh. Don Rickles kind of had that same thing, like he...
我见过其他人这样做。因为，你知道，我尽量礼貌。我尽量对每个人都好，但如果有时我会和我不认识的人开玩笑，即使他们想让我停在他们的桌子旁什么的，只是为了友好，说点关于他们的傻话，然后他们就笑了。唐·里克斯（Don Rickles）也有那种特质，就像他……
Yeah, I mean, and I'm not really Don Rickles, but just the fact that you know me from grownups or something, they want you to just say something, and then I goof around with their kids or something. Right, but like I was walking into this hotel with Kevin Nealon once. This is like two, three years ago, and we walk right into the lobby,
是啊，我的意思是，我并不是真的唐·里克斯，但仅仅因为你从《长大后》之类的电影里认识我，他们就希望你随便说点什么，然后我就和他们的孩子胡闹什么的。对，但就像我曾经和凯文·尼龙（Kevin Nealon）走进这家酒店。这是两、三年前的事了，我们直接走进大堂，
and he passes these two girls, and out of nowhere he goes, oh my God, we were just talking about you. It's so fucking... It's so bizarre. He's so funny. And the girls are like, wait, what? I don't even know you.
他经过这两个女孩，突然间他说，噢，天哪，我们刚才还在谈论你。这太该死了……这太离奇了。他太搞笑了。女孩们就像，等等，什么？我甚至不认识你。
Yeah. It's a great line. It's a great line. But that kind of confidence to just kind of say anything to anybody, anytime, that's why you think you are. Like where does that come from? It's funny, because I'm going to keep not really answering your question,
是啊。那是一句很棒的台词。那是一句很棒的台词。但那种随便对任何人、在任何时间说任何话的自信，这就是为什么你认为你是。那来自哪里？这很有趣，因为我还是不会真正回答你的问题，
but when I was at dinner, sometimes when I'm with dinner, and the ex, actually a while back, she would always infuriate her. You guys probably get this. You say something mildly amusing, and they go, they walk away, and this girl goes,
但当我在吃晚饭时，有时当我吃晚饭时，前任，其实很久以前，她总是会激怒她。你们可能懂这个。你说点稍微有趣的话，他们走开了，这个女孩说，
are you fucking joking? That C-minus dog shit. And then they bust a gut, just because you're on some stupid movie, and I'm like, that's the way it works. And she's like, it's so fucking humiliating and embarrassing. And then in fact, you buy into it, and you're like, hey, that's a real zinger.
你他妈在开玩笑吗？那C减级的狗屎。然后他们笑得前仰后合，仅仅因为你演了什么愚蠢的电影，我就想，事情就是这样运作的。她说，这太他妈丢脸和尴尬了。事实上，你相信了它，你就像，嘿，那真是个绝妙的俏皮话。
And everyone else is going, that was the worst undercooked shit. And then, you know, and then I'm like, hey, you saw it in the last, I'm getting applause breaks. At table 41, we're killing over here. So I sleep with rain sound on my phone, and somebody pointed out that it sounds like applause,
而其他人都在说，那是史上最烂的半生不熟的垃圾。然后，你知道，然后我就想，嘿，你在最后看到了，我得到了掌声。在41号桌，我们在这儿大杀四方。所以我用手机里的雨声睡觉，有人指出那听起来像掌声，
that I need it all night as I'm sleeping. Yeah, that wouldn't be bad, yeah. I was a bus boy, and I was bad. I was like, this sort of answers your question, you know, the piece of it. When I was talking to everyone as a bus boy, I wasn't a stand-up yet. I never even thought about it.
我整晚睡觉都需要它。是啊，那也不错，是啊。我曾是个服务生，而且我很烂。我当时想，这算是回答了你的问题，你知道，其中的一部分。当我作为服务生和每个人说话时，我还没做单口喜剧。我甚至从没想过。
I just was like, hey, and the manager goes, hey, don't talk to the people. You know, that's just sort of the silent guy. Get the dirty shit and walk away. Yeah, and then you go, that's the waiter, you know? And I go, why? Maybe I could be a waiter.
我只是想，嘿，然后经理说，嘿，别和客人们说话。你知道，那只是那种沉默的家伙。拿走脏东西然后走开。是啊，然后你说，那是服务员，你知道？我说，为什么？也许我可以当服务员。
And first of all, I goes, you don't got the stuff. That's what he told me. I go, what's the stuff? It's fucking my job's harder. I lean over and get shit in the waiter just goes, let me take your order. And then, hey, bus boy, do everything. And then I'll be back to get the tip.
首先，他说，你没那两下子。那是他告诉我的。我说，什么是那两下子？这他妈我的工作更难。我弯下腰拿东西，服务员只是说，让我来点餐。然后，嘿，服务生，做所有事。然后我会回来拿小费。
Stack and balance. And when I, yeah, and you know, you lean over and you see the thing in the back that says, to lift, go straight down and straight up. I've never lifted like that in my life. You're always leaning over, and it's like a 20-pound plate burning hot. So then I go, it's Father's Day,
堆叠和平衡。当我，是啊，你知道，你弯下腰，看到后面写着，要抬起，直接向下再向上。我这辈子从没那样抬过东西。你总是弯着腰，那是一个20磅重的滚烫盘子。所以我说，那是父亲节，
and it was in Arizona, too. It was stupid. And they go, the manager gives me the whole talk. And then he goes, and there's a shark on the menu. It says shark special. And it's in Arizona. I don't know. And then I didn't question that part.
而且是在亚利桑那州，太蠢了。他们说，经理给了我一通说教。然后他说，菜单上有鲨鱼。上面写着鲨鱼特餐。而且是在亚利桑那州。我不知道。然后我没质疑那部分。
It's going to be further away from the ocean. Yeah, exactly. We shouldn't have any fish. And Sean would hate it. And so we go in and they go, this table goes, hey, how's the shark? I go, I got a motto. I don't eat them.
离海洋越远越好。是啊，没错。我们不该有任何鱼。肖恩会讨厌它的。所以我们进去，他们说，这桌人说，嘿，鲨鱼怎么样？我说，我有个座右铭。我不吃它们。
They don't eat me. Spank. Can I talk to you? I go, okay. And he goes, what are you doing? I go, crushing. And he's like, dude, what do you not get? Don't fucking talk.
它们不吃我。斯潘克。我能跟你谈谈吗？我说，好的。他说，你在干什么？我说，大杀四方。他就像，伙计，你没明白什么？别他妈说话。
Dude, I'm kidding. I'm getting rolling laughs from three tables that hurt me. And then he fired me. I said, why don't I be a waiter? Then I can do this all the time. He goes, no, we all hate it. What are you doing? I'm crushing, bro.
伙计，我开玩笑呢。我从三桌听我说话的人那里得到了阵阵笑声。然后他解雇了我。我说，为什么我不当服务员？那样我就可以一直这样做了。他说，不，我们都讨厌它。你在干什么？我在大杀四方，兄弟。
Bro, I'm fucking, can you see? I've got this crowd. You're killing my momentum. I'm almost to my closer. And then I go in the back and just eat everything on their plate. I was such a little scumbag. Really? You would hear a buzz boy.
兄弟，我他妈，你能看见吗？我有这群观众。你在破坏我的节奏。我快到我的压轴戏了。然后我走到后面，把他们盘子里所有的东西都吃了。我真是个小人渣。真的吗？你曾是个服务生。
You just have to, that's your dinner. I know I don't have OCD because I eat any food. I don't even see where it came from. I just get in the back. I go, half a steak. I don't know if they put a cigarette out. I don't know anything. I just go and take it.
你只需要，那是你的晚餐。我知道我没有强迫症，因为我吃任何食物。我甚至没看它从哪儿来。我只是走到后面。我说，半块牛排。我不知道他们是不是在上面掐灭了烟。我什么都不知道。我只是去拿了它。
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. David, what was your, what was the audition process for SNL? Because we've had a bunch of people and everybody's got kind of a little bit of a different story. Were you, did you do it in LA? Did you do it in New York? Were you doing groundlings at the time?
我们马上回来。现在回到节目。大卫，你的，《周六夜现场》的试镜过程是什么样的？因为我们请过很多人，每个人都有点不同的故事。你是，你在洛杉矶做的吗？你在纽约做的吗？你当时在做Groundlings吗？
I don't know. I'm going to take this question. Yeah. You might as well. I thought you were going to say, I'm going to take this call. Can you guys hang up one second? You know what? Let's go to the phones for one second.
我不知道。我要回答这个问题。是啊。你最好回答。我以为你要说，我要接这个电话。你们能挂断一秒钟吗？你知道吗？让我们接通电话一秒钟。
Hello? You're on the air with four idiots. So, so I went, I was doing stand up and never thinking of being on SNL. And it was just got to LA from Arizona. And I was getting some spots. I guess who I wound up, guess who I liked that was very funny, Nealon.
喂？你在和四个白痴通话。所以，所以我去了，我当时在做单口喜剧，从没想过要在《周六夜现场》表演。我刚从亚利桑那州到洛杉矶。我得到了一些演出机会。我猜猜我最后，猜猜我喜欢谁，他非常有趣，尼龙。
He was one of my, it kind of an influence because he had that dry delivery, which I never really saw a lot of. So funny. And where he just runs over it. You don't even know it's a joke. I'm like, do these people know that's the funny part? Right. Even I didn't really know.
他是我的，算是一种影响，因为他有那种干巴巴的表达方式，我从没见过很多。太搞笑了。他甚至直接跳过它。你甚至不知道那是个笑话。我心想，这些人知道那是好笑的部分吗？对。甚至我都没真正知道。
He'll come out, he'll, he'll, he'll go to my bathroom. He'll come out, he'll go totally dry. I'll go, Hey, you got a plunger? Every time, every time it comes out of the bathroom. When we're on that lights out show, we have like a little cactus with all these leaves and shit in the middle of the, of the table that we all sit around. And then the commercial goes, Hey, you going to eat that salad?
他会出来，他会，他会，他会去我的洗手间。他会出来，他会完全干巴巴地说。我会说，嘿，你有皮搋子吗？每次，每次他从洗手间出来。当我们做那个《熄灯》节目时，我们桌子中间有一棵小仙人掌，上面有所有这些叶子和乱七八糟的东西，我们都围着坐。然后广告说，嘿，你要吃那个沙拉吗？
And I'm looking around like, what's he talking about? Anyway. Oh yeah. And then in the middle of my monologue, he interrupts me and goes, Hey, what are you going to wear tonight? Anyway, so he goes, so he was very funny and I would watch his act. And then one time I was getting kicked out of the place I was
我环顾四周，心想，他在说什么？不管怎样。噢，是的。然后在我的独白中间，他打断我说，嘿，你今晚要穿什么？不管怎样，所以他说，所以他非常有趣，我会看他的表演。然后有一次我被赶出了我住的地方，
living in this other comedian. I was renting. It was some, you know, it's always like a disaster situation, but he was moving back in. So he kicked me out and, and I go, I don't even know where. And then Neil just happens to go, Oh, I'm moving out. I got SNL. It was way back then, right when I started.
我租给这个其他喜剧演员。那是某个，你知道，总是像灾难一样的情况，但他要搬回来。所以他把我赶走了，然后我说，我甚至不知道去哪儿。然后尼龙碰巧说，噢，我要搬走了。我得到了《周六夜现场》。那是很久以前了，就在我刚开始的时候。
And he goes, if you want to rent my room while I go there, I live with a couple of comedians. And I said, Oh, fuck. Yeah. So he goes, I'll come back. You didn't even ask who the comedians were because that, that, that sounds like, that's a, that's a spicy meatball. Yeah.
他说，如果你想在我去那儿的时候租我的房间，我和几个喜剧演员住在一起。我说，噢，该死。是啊。所以他说，我会回来的。你甚至没问那些喜剧演员是谁，因为那，那听起来，那是个辛辣的肉丸。是啊。
I mean, I didn't even have any choice. I just, one was Bob Dubak, one was a writer and one was Dana Carvey. Wow. And Dana lived above the garage in like just a room and he had his wife with them. They were living there and he was already on SNL. He was like a commune.
我的意思是，我甚至没得选。我只是，一个是鲍勃·杜巴克（Bob Dubak），一个是编剧，一个是达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）。哇。达纳住在车库上面，就像一个房间，他带着他的妻子。他们住在那儿，他已经在《周六夜现场》了。他就像个公社。
Isn't that crazy comedy like Manson camp? So I, So I was not known and Neil was a very friendly guy and, and then, and then they'd go to SNL. And then weeks off, they'd come and Neil would stand a couch, but they would tell me SNL stories and still never cross her mind to do SNL because I wasn't like a character guy.
那不是很疯狂吗，喜剧就像曼森营地？所以我，所以我当时不出名，尼龙是个非常友好的人，然后，然后他们会去《周六夜现场》。然后休息周，他们会来，尼龙会站在沙发上，但他们会告诉我《周六夜现场》的故事，我仍然从没想过要做《周六夜现场》，因为我不是那种角色型演员。
I'm just barely a middle act. Just trying to make sure this is what I'm going to do forever. You know, because I have to make enough to just go, check to check. I still wasn't making money. And then I sort of went way back for your answer, but I know the answer is two and a half minutes. Just tell me when,
我只是勉强算个中间演员。只是想确保这就是我永远要做的事。你知道，因为我必须赚够钱才能，支票对支票。我当时还没赚到钱。然后我为了你的回答走了很远，但我知道答案是两分半钟。只要告诉我什么时候，
No, I love it. I know I'm in. Okay. So then I, You can pick it up probably. Yeah. Right there. It's starting to drag just a little bit.
不，我喜欢它。我知道我在里面。好的。所以然后我，你可能可以接上。是啊。就在那儿。它开始有点拖沓了。
Right there. It dipped a little bit. Yeah. Well, we can probably trim that out, but the thing about comedy up, tangent alert, tangent alert. So anyway, I, I, I, I, they come back, blah, blah, blah.
就在那儿。它稍微下降了一点。是啊。好吧，我们可能可以把它剪掉，但关于喜剧，切题警报，切题警报。所以不管怎样，我，我，我，他们回来，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
And then I do the young comedian special that used to be on HBO. And there was like a host would host it. And Dennis Miller was host. That's right. Will, have you heard the story? And so, I got, I got, Listener wills texting.
然后我做了HBO上过去常有的年轻喜剧演员特辑。有一个主持人会主持它。丹尼斯·米勒（Dennis Miller）是主持人。没错。威尔，你听过这个故事吗？所以，我得到了，我得到了，听众威尔在发短信。
I'm texting because I got Amy's face. I mean, about, cause the kids, my son hasn't finished this homework. Cause it's an even better story. Did you let her know that it's our time right now? Or it was the weekend. Yeah.
我在发短信，因为我看到了艾米的脸。我的意思是，关于，因为孩子们，我儿子还没写完作业。因为这是一个更好的故事。你让她知道现在是我们的时间了吗？或者那是周末。是啊。
So, So, So anyway, I get an audition because they saw this young comedian special and me and Schneider got an audition in New York. So that, that was your answer. I flew to New York.
所以，所以，所以不管怎样，我得到了一个试镜，因为他们看了这个年轻喜剧演员特辑，我和施耐德在纽约得到了一个试镜。所以，那就是你的答案。我飞到了纽约。
And then that audition was stressful, was relaxed. Did you, did you, did you want it or not? Area inducing. Yeah. I wanted it, but I,
然后那个试镜压力很大，很放松。你，你，你想要它还是不想要？区域诱导。是啊。我想要它，但我，
I go, oh, I should, yeah, I would be honest. No, it'd be great. No characters. No idea. Just like sounded great. No plan. So what,
我心想，噢，我应该，是啊，我会诚实的。不，那会很棒。没有角色。没有想法。听起来很棒。没有计划。所以什么，
don't you have to do characters for your audition though? Yeah. They tell you, you have to do a certain. No, I did stand up. So you just did your set. A lot of people just do stand up. And now more and more,
难道你试镜时不需要做角色吗？是啊。他们告诉你，你必须做某个。不，我做了单口喜剧。所以你只是做了你的段子。很多人只是做单口喜剧。现在越来越多，
they're making stand-ups to characters, which fucking sucks. And don't you have to do like an impersonation or no? Yeah. I was just scrambling. I'm like, here's John Bonnet. I love a parade. But I got hired to be a writer.
他们让单口喜剧演员做角色，这他妈太烂了。难道你不需要做模仿吗，或者不需要？是啊。我只是在乱搞。我心想，这是约翰·邦内特（John Bonnet）。我喜欢游行。但我被雇佣做编剧。
And I didn't want to be a writer. I wanted to be you. Yeah. So then did you, okay. Sorry. Don't want to jump ahead, but if a writer and I get hired as a feature,
我不想做编剧。我想成为你。是啊。所以然后你，好的。抱歉。不想跳过，但如果一个编剧，我被雇佣为特约演员，
it's called a writer-performer feature player. So he goes, this is great. This is what Chevy chased it. So you get to write and be on camera or just write for the first year? Jason's like, is it toward the end? No. So I get to.
它被称为编剧兼表演特约演员。所以他说，这太棒了。这就是切维·切斯（Chevy Chase）做的。所以你第一年可以写剧本并出镜，还是只写剧本？杰森就像，是在最后吗？不。所以我可以。
It's foggy at the runway. I go there. Yeah. And I walk around. No. So I just get a brown desk and a legal pad and they just go, this is your week, but no one tells you jack shit.
跑道上有雾。我去那儿。是啊。我走来走去。不。所以我只是得到了一张棕色桌子和一个法律垫，他们只是说，这是你的一周，但没人告诉你任何该死的事。
So we, Rob and I walk around and we see Conan O'Brien. We see, I mean, the writers are fucking hitters. It's Greg Daniels, Conan, Robert Smigel, Jim Downey, and, you know, fucking Bob Odenkirk, and then the cast is Mike Myers and Dana, and all these guys are writing too. So I'm competing against these fucking Frank and, you know, all these writers.
所以我们，罗布和我走来走去，我们看到了柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）。我们看到，我的意思是，编剧们都是他妈的猛将。是格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、柯南、罗伯特·斯密格尔（Robert Smigel）、吉姆·唐尼（Jim Downey），还有，你知道，该死的鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk），然后演员阵容是迈克·迈尔斯（Mike Myers）和达纳，所有这些家伙也在写剧本。所以我是在和这些该死的弗兰克，你知道，所有这些编剧竞争。
And then the cast, and that's the hard part is that we weren't even trying to get on the show at the first. I was like, let me just get to read through without my sketch sucking so fucking bad where everyone looks around and goes, what the fuck? Who spayed? Because you have to put your name on it, unfortunately. So they look at, and they're already like,
然后演员阵容，那是困难的部分，我们起初甚至没想过要上节目。我当时想，让我只要能读完剧本，而我的小品不会烂到他妈的每个人都环顾四周说，这他妈是谁？谁是斯佩德？因为你必须把你的名字写在上面，不幸的是。所以他们看，他们已经像，
you know, low expectations. But then Lauren, you know, you guys have hosted, you read like 45 sketches that read through. And I probably write two, which is harder than shit because most of the hosts were about the same look. You know, like, honestly, like white guy, like a little older, like, you know, it could be Tom Hanks and Alec Baldwin
你知道，低期望。但然后劳恩（Lorne），你知道，你们都主持过，你在读剧本时读了45个小品。我可能写了两个，这比屎还难，因为大多数主持人看起来都差不多。你知道，老实说，就像，白人，稍微年长一点，就像，你知道，可能是汤姆·汉克斯（Tom Hanks）和亚历克·鲍德温（Alec Baldwin），
and then John Malkovich and then Michael Keaton. So your sketches aren't so different, you know? You can't go, oh, it's Melissa McCarthy. Oh, I have a great one for her because it's something we haven't seen for a while. And she does different moves. And this person, it's always fun to get someone different. And if you're not a good writer, which I wasn't,
然后约翰·马尔科维奇（John Malkovich），然后迈克尔·基顿（Michael Keaton）。所以你的小品没那么不同，你知道？你不能说，噢，是梅丽莎·麦卡西（Melissa McCarthy）。噢，我有一个很棒的给她，因为那是我们有一段时间没见过的东西。她做不同的动作。而这个人，找个不同的人总是很有趣。如果你不是个好编剧，我当时就不是，
it's really hard to think differently and write for other people, which is hard. Did you watch SNL before you went through all of this? Like, were you a fan? Like, did you have favorite people? I did watch it growing up and loved it. And that was always like, I think people's favorite years are sort of their years when they were in front of a TV.
真的很难换个角度思考并为别人写剧本，这很难。你在经历这一切之前看过《周六夜现场》吗？就像，你是粉丝吗？就像，你有最喜欢的人吗？我小时候确实看过，而且很喜欢。那总是像，我觉得人们最喜欢的年份就是他们坐在电视机前的那几年。
People say they liked it when I was on. It's usually when they were watching. Did they say, okay, David, just write for a year and if your writing is good, then we'll put you on camera after a year? Or how did they... That's a good question. That was way better than Sean's.
人们说他们喜欢我上节目的时候。通常是他们正在看的时候。他们有没有说，好吧，大卫，你就先写一年，如果写得好，一年后再让你出镜？还是他们怎么……这是个好问题。这比肖恩的问题好多了。
What it was was... Yeah, he usually are. Sean tried to get in another one before you got to see it. He did what I used to do, which is give you a multiple choice for an answer, which ends up elongating things. Jason also likes to answer his own question buried in the question at the midway point.
情况是这样的……是的，他通常都这样。肖恩在你看到之前又想插话。他做了我以前常做的事，就是给你一个多项选择题作为答案，结果把事情搞复杂了。杰森也喜欢在问题中途回答他自己埋在问题里的答案。
We're not journalists. We're not close to it. Listen, I'm doing a podcast. I don't know what the fuck is happening. Dana talks and I just wait and then I say a joke and everyone looks like, why are you talking? I'm like, I'm not. I'm just going to watch.
我们不是记者。我们离那还差得远呢。听着，我在做播客。我根本不知道发生了什么鬼。达纳在说话，我就等着，然后我讲个笑话，每个人都看着我，好像在说，你为什么要说话？我说，我没说。我只是在看。
I love that you guys are doing that together, by the way. I love that you guys are two super hilarious dudes. And it's sort of... When I saw that you guys were doing that, I was psyched. Well, everyone goes, smile as is the greatest show on earth. I know. Do a lot of people sound like that? Well, we didn't videotape it.
顺便说一句，我喜欢你们一起做这件事。我喜欢你们两个超级搞笑的家伙。而且这有点……当我看到你们在做这个的时候，我兴奋极了。好吧，每个人都说，微笑是世界上最棒的节目。我知道。很多人听起来是这样吗？好吧，我们没录像。
And I said, I think we should videotape it because my fans are between six and nine years old and they like things on TV. They like pictures. It's like YouTube. And so, yeah. And they like Legos. Sure.
我说，我觉得我们应该录像，因为我的粉丝在六到九岁之间，他们喜欢电视上的东西。他们喜欢图片。就像YouTube一样。所以，是的。而且他们喜欢乐高。当然。
Hotel Transylvania. So everyone just said, no. And I go, I only know stuff from my stupid Instagram. I don't even know about podcasts. I go, oh, that person? I follow Housing One. Oh, there's a clip from it. So I go, how do I tell people I'm on?
精灵旅社。所以每个人都说，不。我说，我只知道我那愚蠢的Instagram上的东西。我甚至不知道播客。我说，哦，那个人？我关注了Housing One。哦，那里有个片段。所以我说，我怎么告诉别人我在上面？
And they're like, well, that's up to you. I'm like, what? So, well, that's where you come in. I go, I don't know what you mean. Where do I come in? I can't even show it. So they said, smile. And I go, oh, Jesus.
他们说，嗯，那取决于你。我说，什么？所以，嗯，这就是你发挥作用的地方。我说，我不知道你是什么意思。我怎么发挥作用？我甚至没法展示它。所以他们说，微笑。我说，哦，天哪。
Hey, David, when you used to do, how deep into doing SNL, you being on SNL, did you start doing that? Was it called Hollywood Minute? Yes. Oh, God. It gave me so much anxiety. I know me too.
嘿，大卫，当你以前做的时候，你做《周六夜现场》（SNL）有多久了，你上SNL，你开始做那个了？它叫《好莱坞一分钟》吗？是的。哦，天哪。它给了我太多的焦虑。我知道，我也是。
So wait, so. Wait, what is it? It gave me anxiety or it gave me me. No, it gave me so. Because I was definitely on the outskirts of Showbiz. Oh, you get that. Oh, yeah. In the prime target land.
等等，所以。等等，是什么？它给了我焦虑还是它给了我我？不，它给了我……因为我绝对是在娱乐圈的边缘。哦，你懂那个。哦，是的。在主要目标地带。
I would watch that. Which is like, like, like someone watches a horror film through fingers. Tell Tracy what it is. So for Tracy out there, Hollywood Minute was this hilarious segment of weekend update where David would come on like a Hollywood reporter does on the local news station
我会看那个。就像，就像，就像有人透过手指看恐怖片一样。告诉特雷西那是什么。所以对于那边的特雷西来说，《好莱坞一分钟》是《周末更新》中一个搞笑的环节，大卫会像当地新闻台的好莱坞记者一样出现
and he kind of runs down the status of the business and the status of people's careers, et cetera. Sean, Sean, it was so fucking. Do you remember it? No, I totally remember it. I did remember it was Hollywood Minute. But it was always, it was always the scathing truthful underbelly of what the true climate was.
他会梳理一下行业状况和人们的职业生涯状况等等。肖恩，肖恩，这太他妈的了。你还记得吗？不，我完全记得。我确实记得那是《好莱坞一分钟》。但它总是，它总是对真实气候的尖刻真实的底层揭露。
It was a baseball bat to the knees of people. Like if any movie didn't open, he would put a shine of light on. If somebody's career was plummeting, he'd amplify it. Barely plummeting. Yeah. It was just, it was hilarious. Did anybody ever get mad at you?
那是对人们膝盖的一记棒球棍。就像如果任何电影没有开画，他就会照亮它。如果某人的职业生涯在暴跌，他就会放大它。几乎是暴跌。是的。这只是，太搞笑了。有没有人对你生气过？
Did you ever get any? Well, it was always a little dicey because, you know, I'm doing it and then I'm doing it a lot. I'm fucking horny for it. And then we'd be in the writer's room and Jim Downey would go, you would never do that. And we'd throw out jokes. And I go, I go, what about this?
你有没有遇到过？嗯，这总是有点棘手，因为，你知道，我在做它，然后我做得很多。我他妈的对此很渴望。然后我们会在编剧室里，吉姆·唐尼会说，你永远不会那样做。然后我们会抛出笑话。我说，我说，这个怎么样？
And he's like, oh, you're too much of a pussy. I'm like, do you think I am? You know, he's my head writer, my boss bullying me to do it. And cause Downey was like, we all love Downey. He's the best writer. And so, and he wanted these jokes. You know, everyone wants the jokes. They just don't want to do them.
他说，哦，你太怂了。我说，你觉得我是吗？你知道，他是我的首席编剧，我的老板在欺负我去做这件事。而且因为唐尼是那种，我们都爱唐尼。他是最好的编剧。所以，他想要这些笑话。你知道，每个人都想要笑话。他们只是不想自己做。
Right. And I was the conduit to get them out there. And so people would come to me and go, what if he said, and so I start getting, you know, some didn't always do well, but they were more memorable because people were like, oh, this is back when it was People Magazine and that was it. So all celebrities were just catered to.
对。而我是把它们传达出去的渠道。所以人们会来找我，说，如果他说这个会怎样，所以我开始得到，你知道，有些并不总是做得很好，但它们更令人难忘，因为人们会说，哦，这是在《人物》杂志时代，仅此而已。所以所有的名人都被迎合了。
And so no one was saying anything negative. And so I'm like, hey, have you seen this fuck face? And then everyone's like, wait, what? I'm like, God damn that movie sucked. And they're like, so it was probably like 12 jokes in a row. And then I go later and just get out and run hide. Did you ever joke about somebody that had just been a host or somebody that came on a few weeks later that was a host?
所以没有人说任何负面的话。所以我说，嘿，你见过这个混蛋吗？然后每个人都说，等等，什么？我说，该死，那部电影烂透了。他们说，所以这大概是连续12个笑话。然后我后来就跑去躲起来了。你有没有拿刚做过主持人的某人或者几周后来的某人开过玩笑？
I think I did Stone Temple Pilots. And I go, I just heard their album. I liked them the first time I heard them. When they were called Pearl Jam. And then they came on the show about a month later and they said, Marcy Klein goes, Stone Temple Pilots are down there. And the lead singer wants to kick your fucking ass.
我想我做了石庙向导乐队。我说，我刚听了他们的专辑。我第一次听的时候很喜欢他们。当他们叫珍珠果酱乐队的时候。然后他们大约一个月后上了节目，他们说，玛西·克莱恩说，石庙向导乐队在下面。主唱想踢你的屁股。
And I go, are you joking? She goes, not really, no. But we won't let him up here. And I go, well, don't tell him I'm up here. He doesn't know the fucking building. I didn't tell him he run 17. I go, well, I am on 17. Don't throw numbers out.
我说，你在开玩笑吗？她说，不完全是，没有。但我们不会让他上来。我说，好吧，别告诉他我在上面。他不认识这栋该死的楼。我没告诉他他在17楼。我说，好吧，我在17楼。别乱报数字。
And so she goes, so she had to calm him down. And then I want to being good friends with that guy, who's a great guy, Scott. But that was just a throwaway joke. But I don't get how it like hits him to the bone because he's probably, it was one of the first times someone said something like that, you know, to him, which is kind of jokes now seem like old jokes.
所以她说，所以她不得不让他冷静下来。然后我最终和那个家伙成了好朋友，他是个很棒的家伙，斯科特。但这只是一个随意的笑话。但我不明白它怎么会像那样刺痛他，因为他可能，这是第一次有人对他说了那样的话，你知道，这在现在看来就像老笑话。
But then they were sort of newer. When I remember one of the rough ones was a downtown Julie Brown. She left this MTV and she was doing something stupid. And I go, wubba, wubba, wubba. My career's in trouble, trouble, trouble. And then next joke. And people are like, God damn, dude. Oh, here's, here's the bodyguard.
但在当时它们算是比较新的。我记得其中一个比较粗鲁的是市中心朱莉·布朗。她离开了MTV，在做一些愚蠢的事情。我说，哇吧，哇吧，哇吧。我的职业生涯有麻烦了，麻烦，麻烦。然后是下一个笑话。人们说，该死，伙计。哦，这是，这是保镖。
I saw the body. It was the weekend it opened. I saw the bodyguard this weekend. And I want my money back. But I had a really good high pitch. And then, and even though it was a good movie, I just go, well, the joke sounds kind of funny. Yeah.
我看了《保镖》。那是它开画的那个周末。我这个周末看了《保镖》。我想退钱。但我有一个很好的高音。然后，即使那是一部好电影，我只是说，嗯，这个笑话听起来有点好笑。是的。
And not even saw it yet. They don't know. That's the point of it was it would, they were just jokes. Like if anybody, you know, if one of those guys threatened you at valet, you're like, dude, I was just, I don't know you. I'm just making a fucking joke in the moment. Yeah. I talked to Chris Rock about it.
甚至还没看。他们不知道。重点是，它们只是笑话。就像如果任何人，你知道，如果那些家伙在代客泊车时威胁你，你会说，伙计，我只是，我不认识你。我只是在当下开个玩笑。是的。我和克里斯·洛克谈过这件事。
Chris Rock still does it, like when he was doing his act in a, you know, he's like J-Lo. She got here and in her ass came two hours late. And so, but he's doing it right to them and like at an award show and I go, oh, I couldn't do that. That's too rough. That's too hard. But SNL carried and still does carry so much validation power
克里斯·洛克仍然这样做，就像他在表演时，你知道，他说詹妮弗·洛佩兹。她到了这里，她的屁股迟到了两个小时。所以，但他是在颁奖典礼上直接对他们说，我说，哦，我做不到。那太粗鲁了。那太难了。但SNL承载着，并且仍然承载着如此多的验证力量
that by you in that moment, in that bit, being the voice of SNL, there was you were either making or breaking some careers to a certain extent. And it was, it was, it was, you could not not watch. Yeah. SNL does still, you know, people, it's good that it's hanging in there because it has its ups and downs, but there's always something funny. And I wish we had a sketch on Monday. You can see online, you know, there's no online.
以至于你在那一刻，在那个片段中，作为SNL的代言人，你在某种程度上是在成就或毁掉一些职业生涯。而且它是，它是，它是，你不可能不看。是的。SNL确实仍然，你知道，人们，它能坚持下去很好，因为它有起有落，但总有一些有趣的东西。我希望我们周一有个小品。你可以在网上看到，你知道，没有在线。
So you miss it. You miss it for six months until there's a rerun. You know, it's funny, David, you get this a lot. And I just sort of peripherally, I've seen it over the years, you know, when Amy was on the thing where people go like, I don't like SNL anymore. I liked it back when, and that's like the most common thing you hear from people. And I got to see it and I, and it's, I just call such a bullshit on it
所以你错过了。你错过了六个月，直到有重播。你知道，这很有趣，大卫，你经常遇到这种情况。我只是在边缘地带，多年来我见过，你知道，当艾米在那个节目上时，人们说，我不喜欢SNL了。我喜欢以前的，这是你从人们那里听到的最常见的事情。我得去看看，我，我只是觉得这太扯淡了
because, you know, the, you know, the very nature of a sketch show is it's never going to be a hundred percent perfect. You know, if you get one or two good sketches a show, that's a great show. That's any show. That's great. That's every show. It's a show that you remember. So all these seasons are much better in the rear view mirror
因为，你知道，你知道，小品节目的本质就是它永远不会百分之百完美。你知道，如果你一集节目里有一两个好的小品，那就是很棒的节目。那是任何节目。那很棒。那是每一集节目。那是你记得的节目。所以所有这些季节在后视镜里看起来都好多了
because you're only thinking about the good stuff. So, yeah, so people go, I remember the good days when it was this and it's like, no, you fucking don't you fucking liar you have. And they told us we suck. Right, of course. When we were loaded up with everybody. And you guys were loaded and it was amazing. The other thing, David, I've often thought of this.
因为你只想着好的东西。所以，是的，所以人们说，我记得好的日子，那时它是这样的，这就像，不，你他妈的不记得，你这个骗子。他们告诉我们我们烂透了。对，当然。当我们和每个人都混在一起时。你们喝醉了，这太棒了。另一件事，大卫，我经常想到这个。
You came up with an entire sort of joke format which was used and taken and stolen from you for years, which is the, you know, 1999 called and that they want their pants back. That is like an iconic joke format that you created. I think I was in Hollywood minute would do different versions of it. It started with funny. Oh, yeah. Well, there was one, there was one thing when I before I did Hollywood minute,
你想出了一种完整的笑话格式，这种格式被使用、被拿走、被偷走了多年，那就是，你知道，1999年打电话来，他们想要回他们的裤子。那是一个你创造的标志性笑话格式。我想我在《好莱坞一分钟》里会做不同版本的。它始于有趣。哦，是的。好吧，有一件事，在我做《好莱坞一分钟》之前，
I did it and thank you for saying that because that joke has been bent and beat around for years, but I love being a part of it. When I was on Dennis Miller's little talk show, I was really, he was my favorite comedian and so he had a talk show, but toward the end it was going off the air. So people wouldn't go on. I didn't understand that, you know, people start scattering. I wouldn't have any sign of trouble, but it was his last month,
我做了它，谢谢你这么说，因为那个笑话多年来一直被弯曲和敲打，但我喜欢成为它的一部分。当我在丹尼斯·米勒的小脱口秀节目上时，我真的很，他是我的最爱喜剧演员，所以他有一个脱口秀，但在最后它要停播了。所以人们不会去。我不明白这一点，你知道，人们开始四散。我不会有任何麻烦的迹象，但那是他的最后一个月，
but they knew it was canceled. So no one would come on. So I came on, I think three times in two weeks and because he had helped me so much get on SNL. I was like, sure, he's like, Spudly. I said, sure. But the last time I came on in shorts, so disrespectful. But I was like, yeah, I got to go to the Beverly Center.
但他们知道它被取消了。所以没有人会来。所以我来了，我想两周内来了三次，因为他帮了我很多忙才上了SNL。我当时想，当然，他就像，斯帕德利。我说，当然。但最后一次我穿着短裤来，太不尊重人了。但我当时想，是的，我得去比佛利中心。
I definitely, I'll be there. And so I go over there and he goes, short Spud on the talk show. And I go, it's called summer, dude. Look into it. And then when I did the Hollywood Minute, I go, I should do more shit like that. That's funny. So it was like, it's called fashion.
我绝对，我会去那里的。所以我过去，他说，脱口秀上的短裤斯帕德。我说，这叫夏天，伙计。研究一下。然后当我做《好莱坞一分钟》时，我说，我应该多做点那样的烂事。那很有趣。所以就像，这叫时尚。
Look into it. So it was stuff like that. And then in 1997 called him on their hair back, all that stuff. So that was a point of time. But even jokes from movies like Tommy Boyd and stuff where you look back. One of my favorite movies of all time. I think some of them hold up and some, you know, old movies, some movies, some jokes hold up, some don't.
研究一下。所以就是那样的东西。然后1997年打电话来要回他们的头发，所有这些东西。所以那是一个时间点。但即使是像《汤米·博伊》之类的电影里的笑话，当你回顾时。我最喜欢的电影之一。我想有些经得起考验，有些，你知道，老电影，有些电影，有些笑话经得起考验，有些则不然。
But some are original from that movie. Like not just Tommy Boyd. There's a lot of movies where you see it and you go, oh, that's kind of a corny bit. And you go, oh, no, that's where it started. Like, yeah. Well, there's anything wrong with my face. I just, it's not so much here.
但有些是那部电影原创的。就像不仅仅是《汤米·博伊》。有很多电影你看到它，你会说，哦，那是个俗气的片段。然后你说，哦，不，那就是它开始的地方。就像，是的。好吧，我的脸有什么问题吗？我只是，这里没那么多。
It's really, you see any red mark here. Yeah. We kept sending him back to makeup going, it's got to be redder. It's got to be so clear. Yeah. David, who are you hanging out with today other than Carvey? A lot that just makes you fucking bust a gut. Oh.
真的，你看到这里有什么红印吗？是的。我们一直把他送回化妆间说，它必须更红。它必须非常清晰。是的。大卫，除了卡维，你今天和谁在一起？很多让你他妈的笑破肚皮的人。哦。
Comics that I hang out with are Kyle Donaghan, I saw last night, who does a lot of impressions and weird stuff on his Instagram. It's still different. He's not just a straight stand-up. Theo Vaughn, Tim Dillon. There's guys I just see here. Are you getting up on stage lately? I do.
我常在一起的喜剧演员是凯尔·多纳根，我昨晚见了他，他在他的Instagram上做了很多模仿和奇怪的事情。这仍然不同。他不仅仅是一个直白的单口喜剧演员。西奥·沃恩，蒂姆·狄龙。有些家伙我只是在这里见到。你最近上台了吗？我做了。
I did a special. Two weeks ago, this airs in 2023, but I did a special two years ago in 2022. It comes on, I don't know when I'm going to go edit it Sunday, but I did it and it was hard because I was practicing and I haven't done one for a long time. The last was on Comedy Central, which not no one saw, but it's just harder to see.
我做了一个特别节目。两周前，这个在2023年播出，但我两年前在2022年做了一个特别节目。它播出了，我不知道我什么时候去剪辑它，周日，但我做了它，这很难，因为我在练习，而且我已经很久没做过了。上一次是在喜剧中心，没人看，但它只是更难看到。
I wanted it on Netflix. And so actually I ran into Brad Pitt. You guys all know Brad Pitt. Yeah, duh. I never see him, but I saw him somewhere and he goes, I'm seeing all these specials and he's rattling off all these comedians and I'm like, I have to do one just so Brad will see it. That was really the impetus.
我想要它在Netflix上。所以实际上我遇到了布拉德·皮特。你们都知道布拉德·皮特。是的，废话。我从没见过他，但我某处见到了他，他说，我看到了所有这些特别节目，他列举了所有这些喜剧演员，我当时想，我必须做一个，这样布拉德就能看到了。那真的是动力。
He goes, you don't have one. Like I'm not in the business. I go, I've been turning down a lot of stuff lately. You go home, you brush your teeth and you're like, Brad Pitt thinks I'm not in showbiz anymore. He didn't say it out loud, but he was thinking. He's like, die, he's darting around. He's like, who's this fucking clown?
他说，你没有一个。就像我不在这个行业一样。我说，我最近拒绝了很多东西。你回家，刷牙，然后你就像，布拉德·皮特认为我不在娱乐圈了。他没大声说出来，但他心里在想。他就像，戴，他在四处乱窜。他就像，这个他妈的小丑是谁？
We'll be right back. And by the way, let me just take this for all the young folks out there. Throw away your smokes. Cause they're not good for us. Okay. So if you got it in your pocket, nice seeing you as I know where they is, right?
我们马上回来。顺便说一句，让我为所有年轻人说一下。扔掉你们的烟。因为它们对我们不好。好吧。所以如果你口袋里有，很高兴见到你，因为我知道它们在哪，对吧？
Okay. Crush your smokes. All right. Back to the show. David, your show, your talk show lights out was, I just thought it was one of the greatest things that I've seen. I watched it all the time and then I was on it with you.
好吧。掐灭你的烟。好的。回到节目。大卫，你的节目，你的脱口秀《熄灯》是，我只是觉得它是我见过的最伟大的事情之一。我一直看它，然后我和你一起上了它。
You did it. You did a funny bit on it. What happened? Because I thought this is working great. Like a real raw nerve. No, because I didn't understand it. Now the tears come. There they are.
你做了它。你在上面做了一个有趣的片段。发生了什么？因为我觉得这效果很好。就像一根真正的神经。不，因为我不明白。现在眼泪来了。它们就在那里。
It's one of the, it's one of the, it was one of the greatest late night things. Obviously one of the best shows of all time, but that's your words. Now it was a fun show to do. It was fucking hard to do. I don't know. I mean, I'm such a colossal pussy.
这是其中一个，这是其中一个，它是深夜最伟大的事情之一。显然是有史以来最好的节目之一，但那是你的话。现在这是一个有趣的节目。做起来他妈的很难。我不知道。我的意思是，我是一个如此巨大的怂包。
I probably would have. You just seemed so perfect for that, that outlet. Thank you. It was a fun show. It was just four nights a week is hard, but. Yeah. I always assume talk show hosts have the easiest job in the world, but I keep hearing it is one of the hardest jobs in the
我可能本来会。你看起来非常适合那个，那个出口。谢谢。这是一个有趣的节目。只是每周四个晚上很难，但是。是的。我总是认为脱口秀主持人拥有世界上最轻松的工作，但我一直听说它是世界上最难的工作之一。
world. Yeah. They try to make it easy. Like when I hosted Kimmel, they go, you know, that's great. You're coming in the morning. Jimmy comes in seven minutes for the show. Why am I doing here at six AM? But because I don't know how to do it.
是的。他们试图让它变得容易。就像我主持吉米·坎摩尔秀时，他们说，你知道，那太棒了。你早上来。吉米在节目开始前七分钟才来。我为什么要在早上六点在这里？但因为我不知道怎么做。
You know, they're trying to teach me, you know, understand and what to say. But I said, I'm sure he's got it so fucking wired that they have to because it's hard and it's hard to, the hardest part, like even like on a talk show, like a Kimmel is the talking to the guest part. Like this to me is easier in a way. Plus you guys have some help.
你知道，他们试图教我，你知道，理解和说什么。但我说，我相信他已经把它搞得他妈的非常熟练了，他们必须这样做，因为它很难，而且很难，最难的部分，就像在脱口秀上，比如坎摩尔秀，是和嘉宾交谈的部分。这对我来说在某种程度上更容易。加上你们有一些帮助。
Like I have me and Dana and it's, it's still kind of hard, but it's more bullshitty. But on a talk show, it's like that 11 minutes or whatever. And you ask questions and you got to keep it entertaining and balls in the air. And you don't know much about the person. And you have to tee up the promotion of whatever they're selling.
就像我有我和达纳，它仍然有点难，但它更多是胡扯。但在脱口秀上，就像那11分钟或者其他什么。你问问题，你必须保持娱乐性，保持球在空中。而且你对那个人了解不多。你必须为他们正在推销的任何东西做铺垫。
Yeah. And you got to work this and that. And you don't know they're talking backstage. They don't want to get to your clip, but you think they are. Like when you're a guest, you're like, are we, we're out of time. I think I brought a, all right, next time with David. So, you know how it is.
是的。你必须处理这个和那个。而且你不知道他们在后台说话。他们不想进入你的片段，但你以为他们想。就像当你做嘉宾时，你就像，我们，我们没时间了。我想我带了一个，好吧，下次和大卫一起。所以，你知道是怎么回事。
So the, the lights out thing was we went into Corona COVID. Yeah. You know, cause we're in the third year of our two week lockdown right now. And they said two weeks. And then after that, they go, can you just, if we send you it from home on zoom, which a lot of people tried. It was hard to do, but we did it for a while.
所以《熄灯》的事情是我们进入了新冠疫情。是的。你知道，因为我们现在处于两周封锁的第三年。他们说了两周。然后在那之后，他们说，你能只是，如果我们通过Zoom从家里发给你，很多人尝试过。这很难做，但我们做了一段时间。
And then comedy central said a new boss came in and said, we're going to get rid of Tosh and lights out. And we're going to go more animation and stuff. So they did a clean sweep and started over. And I was like, So do you want to do something like that again, that kind of routine, or do you prefer features or doing another TV show or maybe just podcasts and touring and stuff like that.
然后喜剧中心说，一位新老板来了，说，我们要摆脱托什和《熄灯》。我们要转向更多的动画之类的东西。所以他们进行了一次彻底的清理，重新开始。我当时想，所以你想再做那样的事情，那种常规，还是你更喜欢专题片或做另一个电视节目，或者也许只是播客和巡演之类的东西。
Yeah. Well, podcast is new and it will. And it's, it's not, it's kind of fun. It's kind of interesting cause everyone is SNL related. It's about, sort of has a slant. So some are just old friends and some are people I just know who they are. And it's fun to ask them stuff about the show.
是的。嗯，播客是新的，它会。而且它，它不是，它有点有趣。它有点意思，因为每个人都和SNL有关。它关于，有点倾向性。所以有些只是老朋友，有些是我只是知道他们是谁的人。问他们关于节目的事情很有趣。
Cause at least I have some knowledge of it. But I like stand up. Do you enjoy the touring part, like city to city and sexy? Yeah. I mean, I don't, I don't bust my ass, but I do like to get out of fun to go to a city and see how much you sell or what, you know, you do a theater and they go, oh, they want to add a night or something.
因为至少我对此有一些了解。但我喜欢单口喜剧。你喜欢巡演的部分吗，比如城市到城市和性感？是的。我的意思是，我不，我不拼命，但我确实喜欢出去，去一个城市看看你卖了多少票，或者什么，你知道，你做一个剧院，他们说，哦，他们想加一场或者什么的。
Oh, I never even been there. Like that's fun to go and see who's listening and who's watching and who knows you from what after all this time. Now, are you the type of guy that does a show and then goes out afterwards and gets after it and sleeps till three o'clock in the afternoon or. No, that stopped early. That stuff, which is a comics life when I did like the Dallas
哦，我甚至从来没去过那里。就像去看看谁在听，谁在看，谁在这么久之后从什么地方认识你，这很有趣。现在，你是那种做完节目然后出去，然后去搞定它，睡到下午三点的人吗？不，那很早就停止了。那种东西，这是喜剧演员的生活，当我做像达拉斯
and I was starting out and I was a middle on the road, which means you're not the headliner, but you do like 25 minutes. It was such a weird thing that not have any rules. You know, you just want to go have a fucking middle for life. Yeah. I got hired in SNL was still in middle and then you go on headline, you go, I don't even know. I don't have 45 minutes.
我刚开始，我是中间人，这意味着你不是头牌，但你做大约25分钟。没有任何规则真是太奇怪了。你知道，你只是想去过一个他妈的中间人的生活。是的。我被SNL录用了，还是中间人，然后你去当头牌，你说，我甚至不知道。我没有45分钟。
I don't have an hour, but so I go out in middle and then you just have to be somewhere. Is the top the best or the bottom the best? Who's who? Who headlines a top or a bottom? Sean, if you're the middle. Yeah, Sean. Sean.
我没有一个小时，但所以我出去做中间人，然后你只需要在某个地方。顶部最好还是底部最好？谁是谁？谁是头牌，顶部还是底部？肖恩，如果你是中间人。是的，肖恩。肖恩。
Yeah, Sean. I don't understand this question and stand up and stand up world. If you're the headliner, does that make you the top or the bottom? That's the best thing you can be the bottom. What does the bottom mean? Well, I don't know if you say you're the middle.
是的，肖恩。我不明白这个问题，在单口喜剧和单口喜剧世界里。如果你是头牌，那你是顶部还是底部？那是你能成为的最好的事情，底部。底部是什么意思？嗯，我不知道如果你说你是中间人。
That's kind of the top. So the headliner would be the top. Got it. There's opener middle headliner and they just say middle because you're between the opener and the headliner understood. So you actually call and say, Hey, what do you do? You go, I'm a middle. I'm trying to play your club and they go, okay, send me a VHS
那算是顶部。所以头牌会是顶部。明白了。有开场、中间、头牌，他们只是说中间，因为你在开场和头牌之间，明白了。所以你实际上打电话说，嘿，你做什么？你说，我是中间人。我试着去你的俱乐部表演，他们说，好吧，给我发个VHS
of your act shot on a, you know, camcorder somewhere. And then they go, all right. And so I go to these clubs. I got up to making a thousand a week. Sometimes when I did Vegas, it was only 500 a week, but it was 21 shows. And I thought I was King cock. I was happy with it.
你的表演是在某个地方用摄像机拍的。然后他们说，好吧。所以我去这些俱乐部。我最高能赚到一周一千。有时我做拉斯维加斯时，只有一周500，但那是21场演出。我觉得我是国王。我对它很满意。
Now you were going out after that, right? Would you go play the tables? Those I would. And then my friends would come on the road and they go, oh, we got. So you'd go to a club. And what I was getting at is you get a free Hawaiian chicken dinner, which is like chicken with a pineapple on top, a
现在你那时会出去，对吧？你会去玩牌桌吗？那些我会。然后我的朋友们会来路上，他们说，哦，我们有。所以你会去俱乐部。我想要说的是，你得到一份免费的夏威夷鸡肉晚餐，就像上面有菠萝的鸡肉，一个
pineapple ring. And I'd eat that. I'd fucking whoop. Sean's eyebrows are high right now. He's like, where's their shrimp? Could I sub out the, could I sub out? Do you have ahi? Would you ever do, cause you've been on two of the biggest sitcoms,
菠萝圈。我会吃那个。我会他妈的哇。肖恩的眉毛现在很高。他就像，虾在哪里？我可以换掉，我可以换掉吗？你有黄鳍金枪鱼吗？你会做吗，因为你上过两个最大的情景喜剧，
just shoot me in rules of engagement that both lasted years and years. Why do you sitcom again? I mean, probably. Did you like that? Yeah. I'm not really going after too hard. I'm just sort of did start of the podcast doing standup and then I'd
《只是射击我》和《订婚规则》，都持续了多年。为什么你又做情景喜剧？我的意思是，可能。你喜欢那个吗？是的。我并没有真的太努力地去追求。我只是在做播客开始时做单口喜剧，然后我
get ready for my special, which I had to do a little extra standup to rub out the rough edges, finished it, trying to make it. I didn't, I didn't want it to be an hour. Cause I think some people don't last that long watching them, but now it's at an hour 11. I got to still cut it down. And I'm like, ah fuck, I don't know what to cut anymore. I like it.
为我的特别节目做准备，我不得不做一点额外的单口喜剧来磨掉粗糙的边缘，完成了它，试图做它。我不想让它是一个小时。因为我觉得有些人看的时候坚持不了那么久，但现在它是一个小时11分钟。我还得把它剪短。我当时想，啊，该死，我不知道还能剪什么。我喜欢它。
It's so gross. I like my own jokes. It's sickening. No, but that's great. If things are working, that's awesome. Right. And then someone goes, Chris Rock watch. He goes, I feel a special should be 55.
这太恶心了。我喜欢我自己的笑话。这令人作呕。不，但这太棒了。如果事情进展顺利，那太棒了。对。然后有人说，克里斯·洛克看。他说，我觉得特别节目应该是55分钟。
And I go, yeah, me too. Your last one was an hour 31. He goes, I know. Are you saying you're better than me? We all know he is, but I make him say it. What was speaking of rock. So you guys have obviously you and rock and Sandler and, and you guys have all worked together now for like 30 years.
我说，是的，我也是。你上一个是一个小时31分钟。他说，我知道。你是说你比我强吗？我们都知道他是，但我让他说出来。说到洛克。所以你们显然你和洛克和桑德勒，你们现在已经一起工作了大约30年。
Keep doing movies together and bubble. Is this something that like, I don't know, every three years you guys kind of call each other up and go like, Hey, let's, let's go do something where Sandler, the kind of the ringleader and goes like, Hey guys. Usually it starts with Adam, if he has something, but we all just try to do our own stuff. And then if, you know, the grownups is the one that would be fun to do again.
继续一起拍电影和泡泡。这是某种，我不知道，每三年你们就互相打电话说，嘿，让我们，让我们去做点什么，桑德勒是那种领头羊，说，嘿伙计们。通常是从亚当开始，如果他有什么东西，但我们都只是试着做我们自己的事情。然后如果，你知道，《长大成人》是那种会很有趣再做一次的。
I don't think, I don't think you can, unless we do something like that at Netflix because he's moved over there. And that was a Sony movie. Yeah. But that's, people would kill to see all you guys together. But it would be fun to do it. Cause you know, it, listen, we're keeping the lights on a TBS lately because it's,
我不认为，我不认为你可以，除非我们在Netflix上做类似的事情，因为他搬到那里去了。那是索尼的电影。是的。但那是，人们会为了看到你们所有人在一起而杀人。但这会很有趣。因为你知道，它，听着，我们最近在TBS上保持着灯火通明，因为它，
it's on like six times a day and then it's grownups two and then it's bench warmers. Then it's like, you know, it's just on heavy rotation. People are like, it's clockwork orange. They're like, you will see grownups soon. Just stay on this channel. And now is that, are the stories accurate as far as how great and cozy and comfy and cush those shoots are where all these buddies hanging out in some great location with light days and,
它一天播大约六次，然后是《长大成人2》，然后是《板凳队员》。然后就像，你知道，它只是在重播。人们就像，它是《发条橙》。他们就像，你很快就会看到《长大成人》。只要留在频道上。现在是，故事准确吗，关于那些拍摄是多么伟大、舒适、惬意，所有这些伙伴在某个伟大的地方挂着，有轻松的日子，
but you know, listen, Ozark doesn't look like a easy shoot. Yeah. We're all playing. Yeah. We're all playing grab ass. Yeah. It's a hard, everything looks hard when I watch it. I look for night shoots in movies.
但你知道，听着，《黑钱胜地》看起来不像是一个轻松的拍摄。是的。我们都在玩。是的。我们都在玩抓屁股。是的。这很难，当我观看时，一切看起来都很难。我在电影里寻找夜间拍摄。
I go, fuck that. Oh, fuck that. But grownups is mostly daytime, right? Which is already a star for people that don't know. You're like, okay, that's good. And then it is, it's still getting up at five. But he shapes these things so that it is appealing to him, you, the rest of your friends as far as location goes.
我说，去他妈的。哦，去他妈的。但《长大成人》大多是白天，对吧？这对于不知道的人来说已经是一个明星了。你就像，好吧，那很好。然后它确实是，它仍然是五点起床。但他塑造这些东西是为了让它对他，你，你其余的朋友在地点方面有吸引力。
There's an ensemble. So the workload is kind of spread out and all families get to come. Correct? He, on the grownups was where he was really family centric going. We have to cut these jokes. One was we had gone to strip club one night and he's like, absolutely not. We have to do this. And one was this, we was just shaving it down and go, you're sitting with your
有一个合奏。所以工作量有点分散，所有的家庭都能来。对吗？他，在《长大成人》上，他真的很以家庭为中心，说。我们必须剪掉这些笑话。一个是有一天晚上我们去了脱衣舞俱乐部，他就像，绝对不行。我们必须这样做。一个是这个，我们只是把它削减，说，你正和你的
daughter who's nine. Right. That's where I went to come. So what can they see where you don't go, oh shit. I said, okay. So every joke was kind of like, let's keep it funny, but let's do different versions because we're going to nail the one that's good. And when everyone's pretty funny, you huddle up after a take and say,
九岁的女儿坐在一起。对。那就是我去的地方。所以他们能看到什么，你不会说，哦，该死。我说，好吧。所以每个笑话都有点像，让我们保持有趣，但让我们做不同的版本，因为我们要钉住那个好的。当每个人都很有趣时，你在拍摄后聚在一起说，
what if, what if you said this? And then like I go, Adam, what if you say this? And he goes, you know what, give that to rock. And then rock goes, all right, I'll say that. And then bubble up and someone will pitch something and they'll go, Kevin James will, I'll say that. Okay, perfect. Go again, like huddle.
如果，如果你说这个会怎样？然后就像我说，亚当，如果你说这个会怎样？他说，你知道吗，把那个给洛克。然后洛克说，好吧，我会说那个。然后泡泡起来，有人会提出什么，他们会说，凯文·詹姆斯会，我会说那个。好的，完美。再来一次，就像聚在一起。
And then we go back to it and then we come in and go, what about this? And Adam would always pepper the jokes around. So you could have cut that movie, right? Every joke in the movie. Cause every scene, you have one, you have something and he has to give it. Like, but he, he gives himself almost the least. He, he's the main character. He's like the Seinfeld and he's like, you do this, you go off and do that.
然后我们回到它，然后我们进来，说，这个怎么样？亚当总是会把笑话撒在周围。所以你可以剪掉那部电影，对吧？电影里的每个笑话。因为每个场景，你有一个，你有什么，他必须给它。就像，但他几乎给了自己最少。他，他是主角。他就像《宋飞正传》，他就像，你做这个，你去那边做那个。
You say that joke, gives himself some fun, but isn't selfish. And then it's still a five AM shoot. It's still a shoot. And you know, Adam has to sit there and wrangle us when we're all me and Sam and Hayek and rock are talking over here and Schneider's over there. And he's like, guys, guys, fucking, and then you only have two lines. So you get to your line and he goes, Spade, I, oh, shit. Oh, is that me?
你说那个笑话，给自己一些乐趣，但并不自私。而且它仍然是五点拍摄。它仍然是一个拍摄。而且你知道，亚当必须坐在那里，当我们都在我和萨姆和海耶克和洛克在这里说话，施耐德在那里时，他必须管住我们。他就像，伙计们，伙计们，他妈的，然后你只有两句台词。所以你到了你的台词，他说，斯佩德，我，哦，该死。哦，那是我的吗？
So he's writing, is writing, producing, directing and first day deeing, right? He's such a generous guy, right? He's incredible. And he's good with it. And then those wind up being a lot of fun and sure it's work, but in the, in the work world, it's the best way because at least at night you can go eat with someone or at least on the set, you can go bullshit with someone. Cause a lot of things you do, like I did father of the year after that.
所以他在写，在写，制作，导演和第一天，对吧？他是一个如此慷慨的家伙，对吧？他太不可思议了。而且他做得很好。然后那些最终变得非常有趣，当然这是工作，但在工作世界里，这是最好的方式，因为至少在晚上你可以和某人一起吃饭，或者至少在片场，你可以和某人胡扯。因为很多你做的事情，比如我之后做了《年度父亲》。
Oh, a couple of people remember. Thank you. Yeah. It was Adam's nephew was directing who was new at it and he wound up directing Wrong Missy, but that was his first thing. And Adam goes, do you want to do this? And I think it's pretty funny. I think you'd be good in it. And I read it and it was like low budget.
哦，几个人记得。谢谢。是的。是亚当的侄子在导演，他对此很陌生。他最终导演了《错配搭档》，但那是他的第一件事。亚当说，你想做这个吗？我觉得这很有趣。我觉得你会很适合它。我读了它，它就像低预算。
Like I said, yeah, I read it. I thought it was funny and but it was in the cold. It was not grownups. It was freezing. It was raining every single day. And I didn't know anybody. And so it was a whole different ballgame of like, Oh, it's back to work. And you guys have done stuff where it's just work and you go and you go,
就像我说，是的，我读了它。我觉得它很有趣，但它在寒冷中。它不是《长大成人》。它冻死了。它每天都在下雨。而且我不认识任何人。所以这是一个完全不同的球赛，就像，哦，回到工作了。你们做过只是工作的事情，你去，你说，
I just got to do it. And then you, the only joy really is you're doing takes where you think maybe you nailed something funny or me and it started to come together as I shot it. I go, this is pretty funny for me. Right. And so when it ended, you don't know, it's just you're shooting out a sequence. You don't know if it's any good. And they cut it together.
我只是得做它。然后你，唯一的快乐真的是你在做拍摄，你认为也许你钉住了一些有趣的东西，我，它开始在我拍摄时结合在一起。我说，这对我来说很有趣。对。所以当它结束时，你不知道，你只是在顺序拍摄。你不知道它是否好。然后他们把它剪在一起。
When I saw it, I said, Oh, good. I like this one. Do you, do you like, you know, from the outside for me, such a big fan and you know, we email and we're friends and whatever. But I look at you and I go SNL at two massive sitcoms, movies, touring with your stand up. Like the success is just really huge. And is there anything left that you or anything that you haven't really
当我看到它时，我说，哦，好。我喜欢这个。你，你喜欢，你知道，从外面看，对我来说，作为一个大粉丝，你知道，我们发邮件，我们是朋友，等等。但我看着你，我说SNL，两个巨大的情景喜剧，电影，带着你的单口喜剧巡演。像这样的成功真的很大。还有什么剩下的，或者有什么你还没有真正
conquered yet that in, in this world that you're like, yeah, if I could just blank, you know, get blank or whatever, or are you, or is it just like gravy? Maybe one more. Yeah. What's the record on that? Is that what you're chasing? Is it?
征服的，在这个世界上，你就像，是的，如果我能只是空白，你知道，得到空白或者什么的，或者你是，或者这就像肉汁？也许再来一个。是的。那个的记录是什么？那是你在追求的吗？它是吗？
Well, razzies. The really one that got me was. Do they even still do those? I mean, it's so fucking stupid that, that they do it and gets all the attention and then they just make up things. Now the best one, which was really quick, David, for Tracy or Razi is a, is an award for the worst performance or the worst movie or whatever. Who's Tracy?
嗯，金酸莓奖。真正抓住我的是。他们现在还做那些吗？我的意思是，这太他妈的愚蠢了，他们这样做，并得到所有的关注，然后他们只是编造东西。现在最好的一点，这真的很快，大卫，对于特雷西或拉齐来说，是一个奖项，为了最差的表演或最差的电影或什么的。特雷西是谁？
My sister in Wisconsin. Who doesn't know shop talk, so we gotta break it down. Oh, Tracy. Wait, what about the Razi? Oh, the Razi is, I was in Jack and Jill and I was up for worst actress. And Sam was up for worst actor and actress. That's pretty funny. And I was like, okay, Razi's, you got one funny one in there.
我在威斯康星州的妹妹。她不知道行话，所以我们得把它分解。哦，特雷西。等等，金酸莓奖怎么样？哦，金酸莓奖是，我在《杰克与吉尔》里，我被提名为最差女演员。萨姆被提名为最差男演员和女演员。那太搞笑了。我当时想，好吧，金酸莓奖，你在里面有一个有趣的。
Good job. David, to give us, give us, give us an update, a status, all the ups, all the downs about the personal life. I want it all. I want, I want, I want, I want pets, mates. Oh, really? Just a quick, quick appeal. Well, how's, how's personal life?
干得好。大卫，给我们，给我们，给我们一个更新，一个状态，关于个人生活的所有起起落落。我想要全部。我想要，我想要，我想要，我想要宠物，伴侣。哦，真的吗？只是一个快速，快速的呼吁。嗯，个人生活怎么样？
Exciting, boring. What's, what's, what's up with it? We got dumped. We know that, that he learned that. Oh, really? Yeah. Now I'm, oh right. Tracy goes, oh really?
令人兴奋，无聊。什么，什么，什么情况？我们被甩了。我们知道那个，他学到了那个。哦，真的吗？是的。现在我，哦，对了。特雷西说，哦，真的吗？
That was toward the beginning when you weren't really. Yeah. My, my, my ram is filled. No, I, I'm, I moved. I live near Sunset Plaza now. And then that was in the paper, which is a new thing. Truly? Like a real estate.
那是接近开始的时候，当你不是真的。是的。我的，我的，我的内存满了。不，我，我搬家了。我现在住在日落广场附近。然后那在报纸上，这是一个新事物。真的吗？就像房地产。
This guy moved. Here's his house. Here's how much it costs. Here's the realtor. Here's photos of it. Here's why you can't afford it. I just went through the same thing in August and. I saw your house.
这家伙搬家了。这是他的房子。这是它花了多少钱。这是房地产经纪人。这是它的照片。这是为什么你买不起它。我刚在八月经历了同样的事情，而且。我看到了你的房子。
That's right. Yeah. Yeah. There you go. I saw him and something and I was like, look at this fucker. And then you know what I did is I would, I would judge people by their, no, not, not on purpose, but I would just think, this is the Caprio's need to tear or whatever that means.
那是对的。是的。是的。你去吧。我在某处看到了他，我当时想，看看这个混蛋。然后你知道我做了什么，我会，我会根据他们的判断人，不，不，不是故意的，但我只是会想，这是卡普里奥的需要撕裂或者那意味着什么。
First of all, I go, it's two million. That's all he's got. That's first thing. Then, and then I go, oh, he's got that lamp in his kitchen. Jesus. But then when I sold my house, they go, the most embarrassing thing is they go, well, this place is obviously a tear down. I go, oh, what?
首先，我说，它是两百万。那是他所有的。那是第一件事。然后，然后我说，哦，他的厨房里有那盏灯。天哪。但当我卖掉我的房子时，他们说，最尴尬的事情是他们说，嗯，这个地方显然是一个拆除。我说，哦，什么？
My beautiful fucking mansion. And they're like, well, I go, I have a tennis court. I will bring two tennis targets and some dynamite because we got to just take it down to the fucking nails. And they go, you're joking. I go, I live, they go, you don't live here. Do you? I go, well, no, no, no, I don't live here.
我美丽的该死的豪宅。他们就像，嗯，我说，我有一个网球场。我会带两个网球目标和一些炸药，因为我们必须把它拆到该死的钉子。他们说，你在开玩笑。我说，我住，他们说，你不住在这里。对吗？我说，嗯，不，不，不，我不在这里住。
I mean, I stay here. But I was so embarrassed. They were shitting on it. And then they go, I go, all right. So I had these five realtors and four were like, it's probably a tear down. I go, so that makes me sick. And then the fifth one goes, well, okay, if you just leave it like this, you're going to, um, stage it.
我的意思是，我待在这里。但我太尴尬了。他们在上面拉屎。然后他们说，我说，好吧。所以我有了这五个房地产经纪人，四个就像，它可能是一个拆除。我说，所以这让我恶心。然后第五个说，嗯，好吧，如果你只是把它留成这样，你会，嗯，布置它。
I go, I'm going to what? And they go, stage it. And I go, what does that mean? They go, put furniture in here. I go, I have furniture in here. They're like, well, not this Z gallery bullshit. Like we got to come in here and like clean the corners and get some like light in here and some life.
我说，我要什么？他们说，布置它。我说，那是什么意思？他们说，把家具放在这里。我说，我有家具在这里。他们就像，嗯，不是这种Z画廊的胡扯。就像我们必须进来，清理角落，让这里有一些光，一些生命。
And I'm like, what the fuck? This place is, it's unreal. And they go, and then my realtor's nodding his head going, hey, man, I wanted to break it to you. So literally all my dreams just crashed. I have to stage it. So the point is I see these things on these photos. And I go, they didn't even, that's not even where their house is.
我当时想，这他妈的是什么？这个地方是，它不真实。他们说，然后我的房地产经纪人在点头说，嘿，伙计，我想告诉你。所以字面上我所有的梦想都破碎了。我必须布置它。所以重点是我在这些照片上看到这些东西。我说，他们甚至没有，那甚至不是他们的房子所在的地方。
Like mine looks so different now. I don't even know what it is. Like that's my house. Okay. What my house would be, uh, so embarrassing if I didn't have the, the, the taste of, uh, but the other half of my life going in, fixing all the crappy taste I have. Um, or Jason, your house used to belong to, you guys bought it from the state. It used to belong to, um, uh, Ernest Borgnine.
就像我的现在看起来太不同了。我甚至不知道它是什么。就像那是我的房子。好的。我的房子会是，呃，如果我没有，呃，品味，太尴尬了，但我的另一半生活在进去，修复我所有的糟糕品味。嗯，或者杰森，你的房子曾经属于，你们从州里买的。它曾经属于，嗯，呃，欧内斯特·博格宁。
Ernest Borgnine. Yeah. Yeah. No, by the way, who famously somebody said, how do you stay alive? You know, live so long and he famously said by jerking off every day. So do you ever have that thought of him jerking off all around that? Is that true? That's a true quote.
欧内斯特·博格宁。对。对。顺便问一下，是谁有名地说过，你是怎么保持活力的？你知道，活那么久，他有名地说是因为每天自慰。所以你有没有想过他到处自慰的事？那是真的吗？那是一句名言。
Is it really? Shit. Hang on a second. Look it up. Look it up. That's going to haunt you. Every room that you go when you're sitting with your family, you guys are having a nice meal.
真的吗？该死。等一下。查一下。查一下。那会困扰你的。当你和家人坐在一起，你们正在吃一顿美餐时，你去的每个房间都会想到这个。
Imagine him standing against the wall, leaning against the wall with one hand, the other one. He's just rubbing one out. He's thinking, I'm going to live so long. I'm going to live so fucking long. Where was that little chestnut when I was thinking about buying the place? What we're doing on the street is he's a real squirter. Is he?
想象一下他靠在墙上，一只手撑着墙，另一只手在……他只是在打手枪。他心想，我会活很久。我会活得他妈的很久。当我考虑买那个地方时，那个小道消息去哪了？我们在街上做的是，他真是个喷射狂。是吗？
He's got legs. So I'm living in a goo shack. It's just goo every week. Baby goo shack. Oh yeah. David Spade. And then they, oh, and then I'll tell you this, then you can wrap up. I know Sean's, I got to go.
他很有活力。所以我住在一个粘液小屋里。每周都是粘液。宝贝粘液小屋。哦，对。大卫·斯佩德。然后他们，哦，然后我告诉你这个，然后你就可以结束了。我知道肖恩的，我得走了。
I got to go too. Don't worry about that. So, uh, so then someone offers me when I go to sell, it did sell. Just tear it down. It did sell. Thank God. But they go, uh, they offer me half money and half bitcoins. I go, what the?
我也得走了。别担心那个。所以，呃，然后有人在我去卖的时候提出报价，确实卖了。把它拆了吧。确实卖了。谢天谢地。但他们说，呃，他们给我一半现金和一半比特币。我说，什么鬼？
I heard that. Yeah. I know. I go, I mean, they're stupid or dumb. But I go, I don't know. Then they go, we can get you a condo in the metaverse. I go, well, on a good street. I don't even know what I'm talking about.
我听说了。对。我知道。我说，我的意思是，他们是傻还是笨。但我说，我不知道。然后他们说，我们可以给你在元宇宙里弄个公寓。我说，嗯，在好地段吗？我甚至不知道自己在说什么。
What? And I go, I'm going to wind up in some shitty apartment in a Ruby Tuesdays website. I know what's going on here. I'll be way, way away from anything cool. And they go now. So I didn't, I didn't sell it for that. I took, I go, I'm just looking for money right now at this junkyard. I don't need a file.
什么？我说，我最终会落得在Ruby Tuesdays网站上的某个破公寓里。我知道这里发生了什么。我会离任何酷的东西都远远的。他们说现在。所以我没有，我没有为了那个卖掉它。我拿了，我说，我现在在这个垃圾场只是想要钱。我不需要文件。
And they're like, oh, then we're out. Oh my God. Then we're out. I don't even, NFB. Is that what it's called? An NFB or something like that? Yeah. NFT.
他们就像，哦，那我们不买了。天哪。那我们不买了。我甚至不知道，NFB。那是它的名字吗？NFB还是类似的东西？对。NFT。
You want an NFT of my house? Then I keep the house. We have a picture of it. That's a million. Oh, good God. David Spade. I wish we could go on and on. You have to go.
你想要我房子的NFT？那我就留着房子。我们有一张它的照片。那是一百万。哦，天哪。大卫·斯佩德。我希望我们能一直聊下去。你得走了。
I have to go. We have to go. But it's been such a pleasure. Thanks for making this laugh. Thank you guys. That was, that felt like fun. It felt like fun. It felt like fun.
我得走了。我们得走了。但这真是太愉快了。谢谢你们让我笑。谢谢你们。那，感觉很有趣。感觉很有趣。感觉很有趣。
It was such a pleasure. Thanks for making this laugh. That was, that felt like five minutes. Spade, you're so fucking hilarious all the time. Yes, you are. One of the funniest alive. Fucking every time, just hilarious. It's good to have a bullshit session with you guys because it's always a quick brief
这真是太愉快了。谢谢你们让我笑。那，感觉就像五分钟。斯佩德，你一直都他妈的太搞笑了。是的，你是。活着的最有趣的人之一。他妈的每次，都太搞笑了。和你们一起胡扯真是太好了，因为总是很简短
talk. Come over to Jen's a little bit more often, be a bigger part of our lives. Come over to the clubhouse. Jen's for Tracy is a restaurant we go to. She always has good food in there. Tracy, Tracy, I was in, how would she know me? She knows exactly who you are. She's a big fan.
谈话。多来珍家几次，成为我们生活的重要部分。来会所吧。珍家是我们要去的餐厅。她那里的食物总是很好。特蕾西，特蕾西，我在，她怎么会认识我？她完全知道你是谁。她是你的忠实粉丝。
She's a big fan. Thanks guys. And I will talk to you soon. I appreciate it. Thanks, David. All right, buddy. See you soon, man. All right.
她是你的忠实粉丝。谢谢你们。我很快会和你们联系。我很感激。谢谢，大卫。好的，伙计。回头见，伙计。好的。
Have a great day. Bye-bye. He is, he is such a unique community. Like nobody, nobody really does what he does. You know, like I think it's hard to carve out a unique space in comedy and he has had that and held that from the very beginning. Quick dry wit. Really quick dry.
祝你有美好的一天。再见。他，他是一个如此独特的人。就像没有人，真的没有人像他那样。你知道，我觉得在喜剧中开辟一个独特的空间很难，而他从一开始就拥有并保持着那个空间。敏捷而冷幽默。非常敏捷而冷幽默。
And like I said, like it really made me double over when he just zero kind of, we weren't even talking and the guy's doing this bit and he literally in the driest possible way just over his shoulder goes, he makes you look like a good actor and it just out of nowhere. We weren't even, and it just killed me and I'm like, God, it's so funny, so quick. It was him being a waiter and the guy going, what are you doing? What about the shark? The shitty joke about the shark?
就像我说的，当他只是零，我们甚至没在说话，那家伙在做这个段子，他字面上用最冷淡的方式越过肩膀说，他让你看起来像个好演员，这简直是突如其来。我们甚至没在，这简直笑死我了，我想，天哪，太搞笑了，太敏捷了。那是他扮演服务员，那家伙问，你在做什么？关于鲨鱼的那个烂笑话呢？
I don't eat them. They don't eat me. So fucking funny. So funny. He is so great. Consistently, always off the cuff. You know, he, yeah, and he, he's been in the business for so long. It's not like you forget about it because he's always there, but you forget like anything,
我不吃它们。它们不吃我。太他妈搞笑了。太搞笑了。他太棒了。始终如一，总是即兴发挥。你知道，他，是的，而且他，他在这个行业待了太久了。并不是说你会忘记他，因为他总是在那里，但你会忘记像任何事情一样，
his brilliance and you need to be reminded that these people are out there. So I don't know. He's, he's one of the greatest. Yeah, I'd like to see him back on something super high profile, you know, whether it's like another TV show or series of movies or like, I mean, the podcast is great and everything, but I want to see him. Yeah, I want to see him a lot more. And that's why I thought that talk show was going to be his thing and work.
他的才华，你需要被提醒这些人就在那里。所以我不知道。他，他是最伟大的人之一。是的，我想看到他回到一些超级高调的项目上，你知道，无论是另一部电视剧还是系列电影，或者，我的意思是，播客很棒，什么都好，但我想要看到他。是的，我想看到他更多。这就是为什么我认为那个脱口秀会是他的拿手好戏并成功。
But you know, he mentioned his, the location of his new home, you know, where the section of LA that it's in. Yeah. And I don't live too far from there. In fact, I live really near. Bye. No one's ever trying quicker to get to the buy the job. Have a good rehearsal today.
但你知道，他提到了他的，他新家的位置，你知道，它在洛杉矶的哪个区域。是的。我住得离那儿不远。事实上，我住得非常近。再见。从来没有人比这更快地去买工作。今天排练顺利。
Sean. Bye everybody. Bye bud. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
肖恩。大家再见。再见伙计。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. And crafted by Bennett Barbacoff, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjooarff. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。由Bennett Barbacoff，Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjooarff制作。聪明。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。